now to a cbs news investigation of a
mysterious ailment commonly called
havana syndrome affecting u.s officials
who have reported pain physical pain
conditions while serving overseas we're
hearing from former u.s government
operatives about what they say are the
consequences of the ailment a few spoke
with senior investigative correspondent
katherine herrich about their struggle
for recognition and financial and
medical help from the government
catherine good morning what did they
tell you
good morning nate working through
multiple intelligence and legal contact
cbs news has identified more than a
dozen current and former government
operatives and in some cases their
families who told us the government has
not had their backs
my brain
is broken marriage is the beginning at
her small backyard wedding former cia
analyst erica stith felt exhausted and
overwhelmed from the other day that
changed her life everything kind of
changed in an instant just like that
just like that stith who says she held a
top secret security clearance believes
she was targeted by an intense attack of
energy waves i would liken it to
kind of
an electronic sniping that she says led
to crippling consequences nausea
yes headaches yes blurred vision yes
balance and memory issues yes
are you suffering yes yes
suffering that she says began in 2018
while on assignment in europe for the
cia at first stith blamed a prior
concussion but soon became so unsteady
she fell down the stairs who put it
together my mom
and honestly she had been asking me for
six months people this havana syndrome
thing do you think you could have that
havana syndrome is a mysterious set of
cognitive and neurological ailments
named after cases reported among
diplomats at the u.s embassy in cuba it
is a well-conceived
global program to attack americans
former deputy national security adviser
charles kupperman tracked suspected
havana syndrome attacks for the trump
administration the number if you include
family members is close to a thousand a
thousand people
and not just overseas kupperman said two
government staffers were attacked here
just steps from the white house it tells
us that somebody is very serious about
sending us a message that they can reach
out and do
very bad things to our employees at the
highest levels last year president biden
signed legislation for medical and
financial help my administration is
coordinating a government-wide effort to
respond to these incidents but this
email obtained by cbs news suggests
access to a key government treatment
program for some victims could end in
three weeks for us to abandon them now
is really a disgraceful act after cbs
contacted the national security council
a spokesman said they are committed to
ensuring that our current and former
personnel receive the specialized
medical care that they need for as long
as they need it here are my mri results
stis documents show she spent months
going back and forth with the cia for
care as a former employee but ultimately
declined to share her medical records
with the agency by the time they came
back to me and said okay we have a
process in place
i had already successfully
talked my way into a treatment program
and i had managed to make that happen
privately
and have been paying for it myself you
gave up on the process completely what
do you want people to know
we got this
as a result of serving our country
and we deserve to be taken care of stith
who now uses hearing aids and takes up
to 20 pills a day applied for permanent
disability through the cia and faces an
uncertain future with all the medication
can you start a family no
there are medications that are
counter-indicated for pregnancy it would
not be safe
and on top of that i'm not sure i'll
ever be able to work again i mean i've
i've lost everything
in response to our investigation the
administration's top coordinator on the
issue said we remain intensely focused
on providing rapid and effective care to
effective personnel the cia said it
doesn't comment on individual cases but
emphasized the agency is committed to
ensuring access to care adding we
continue to bring all resources to bear
to explore all possible causes in our
ongoing investigations so far the cia
does not tie a foreign or hostile actor
to these reported incident scale
catherine thank you very much